hi everyone this is Jerry and this is a
game between a former world champion
josé raúl capablanca who's playing the
white pieces versus Edgard collie
playing the black pieces this game was
played in Barcelona in 1929 and I think
it's a good illustration of positional
play by white which ends with just a
little tactic towards the very end of
the game to finish black off so as the
game went white starts out with pawn to
c4 signalling the English opening night
f6 development at f3 development on c5
Knight c3 Knight c6 and what we have is
asymmetrical English opening where both
Knights have been developed classically
and both si puns have advanced two
squares that symmetry ends with White's
next move pawn to d4 and that's often
the case in chess as soon as there is
upon tension or some exchange occurs
that's pretty much the end of any
symmetry pawn takes pawn Knight takes
pawn and blacks next move pretty much
puts him in some hot water it's pretty
much a rough road ahead after Knight
takes Knight and Queen takes Knight
because this queen is very nicely placed
in the center of the board and she isn't
very accessible to the black pieces she
cannot be very easily chased away from
this d4 square maybe a better
continuation for black at this point in
the game for move 5 is to just follow up
with maybe pawn to g6 and play Bishop to
g7 or more specifically just to keep
this tension between the Knights and
that help light out by developing their
queen to the d4 square but as it went
we had Knight takes Knight Queen takes
Knight and now upon the g6
pawn to e4 making way for the Bishop to
develop
pawn to d6 don't get into the habit of
having moves like pawn to g6 if you're
playing the black pieces here don't get
into the habit of playing pawn to g6 and
Bishop to g7 back-to-back you need to
take into account positioning of the
white pieces if you play Bishop g7 and
after cope with pawn to e5 the Knights
attacked if it goes to h5 pawn to g4
traps it if the knight goes to g8 well
is that really how you want to be
treating your knight came to f6 and now
it goes back home probably doesn't want
to have to do that so instead of Bishop
g7 in this position that's why pawn to
d6 is played to Guardi 5 so in the event
of e5 the pawn could be taken Bishop to
e3 development and white is actually
already anticipating that this Queen is
going to be attacked so when this bishop
comes here eventually White's going to
want to retreat to d2 and that's why
this Bishop wants to first be developed
to III so that the queen is on d2 and
the bishop is on e3 ship to g7 on f3
pawn f3 is directed at garden g4 so that
the knight can't make use of that Square
and attack the bishop on e3 Queen to a5
pinning the knight to the King and
really raking this whole 5th rank you
know probably better is just to castle
immediately making the move that you
know you're going to have to make right
away instead of already telling white
the address of your queen but as it went
Queen a5 and now Queen to d2 breaking
the pin on the knight and getting out of
the view of this Bishop pawn to a6
defending b5 from maybe a move like
Knight to b5 and also supporting a pawn
to b5 advance that's one of the breaks
that black is trying to maybe get in
this position this pawn to b5 in many
Sicilian defenses black looks to get
this pawn to d5 advance in but that's
all the more difficult as a result of
this pawn
c4 is contributing to the defense of
this d5 square as is many other pieces
the e4 upon the knight on c3 the Queen
on d2 all of them are focused on this d5
square so b5 is the next is the next try
and seems like that would be the one
that's a bit more manageable to get in
Bishop to e2 development preparing the
castle a good question here is why not
play to d3 you know what's the
difference between the two moves well
take into account that this is a half
opened e-file since there is no white
pawn but a black pawn and the heavy
pieces namely the Queens and the rooks
are going to want to have a clear view
of this d6 pawn but if the bishop is on
d3 you're essentially putting a
blindfold over the Queen on d2 it cannot
see this d6 pawn directly so that's why
we have Bishop e2 Bishop e6 attack c4
it's defended once and attacked once so
we could consider it unprotected just as
we consider this b7 pawn unprotected the
b7 pawn has zero attackers zero
defenders it's unprotected the c4 pawn
has one attacker one defender we can
consider that unprotected as well rook
c1 getting out of any potential threat
along this diagonal now this rook might
be susceptible to some tactics from this
bishop on g7 after some pieces have
moved namely this knight eventually
white wants to play pawn to b3 to have a
pawn defend this c4 pawn so as soon as
this b2 pawn moves this the rook that
was on a1 might have been a bit more
susceptible to tactics rook c8 adding
pressure to c4 upon b3 defense and
notice how this rook is no longer on the
a1 square actually there's been a couple
moves made now the Queen and the rook
have gotten out of the
Bishop's view of this diagonal now we
have Knight to d7 just having this
bishop have direct view of the c3 Knight
and the knight has possibilities of
hopping the c5 or e5 at some point white
castles black castles and now we have
Knight to d5 a very forcing move in fact
there's only one good reply from this
position seeing how this Queen is
unprotected and this Knight is
unprotected how to cope with both
threats
unfortunately Queen takes Queen losses
upon due to the in-between move Knight
takes pawn check King in the corner
Bishop takes Queen the end result is
white is up upon so unfortunately black
is having to retreat the Queen to its
home in other Queen
well she's not ideally placed such that
she has to essentially watch over upon
the knight he's attacking upon the Queen
is having to watch over the pun not the
ideal placement for a Queen Queen to be
for attacking an unprotected piece
you'll see that in many instances in
this game white pretty much puts
pressure on black by attacking
unprotected points in the position so b7
is the unprotected point so that's why
we have this puppet Queen to b4 move
Bishop takes Knight how to recapture
this Bishop which one which one of these
pawns do you capture with pawn on C
takes Bishop the reason for that is to
allow this rook more activity as well as
this bishop notice that this pawn
obstructs the view of this rook and this
Bishop as soon as this pawn recaptures
this rook has more options namely c5 c6
c7 and c8 and this Bishop could
potentially come to be five or a six at
some point those aren't necessarily good
moves but at least more possibilities
exist so that's why we have
opponents eat takes bishop and this this
thread is still in the air so how to
cope with it unfortunately black has to
give up control of the C file or at
least thinks that that's the way to best
cope with this position if the rook
tries to go here to defend this pawn
that'll just run into Bishop to a7 the
rooks attacked and as soon as it moves
Queen takes pawn so that's really not a
good defense so a black chooses to swap
rooks gives White control of the C file
a positional asset and not going to be
eight defends the pun going to c4 and
move directed at just pretty much saying
I have controlled the C file so there's
no rook to c8 move Bishop to b2 move
that's a difficult move to explain it's
pretty much a and I don't know what to
do move because it doesn't really
accomplish much if anything it actually
improves the placement of the white rook
if I'm playing the white pieces here I
would much rather have my rook on a
light Square opposed to a dark square
since my opponent has one Bishop
remaining in that Bishop is on a dark
square so I just well white plates plays
the move rook to c2 and the bishop just
goes to f6 so really what was
accomplished really not a whole lot with
that move I probably should have just
come here right away but as it went we
have now pawn to f4 preparing in advance
pawn to e5 and also taking away
possibilities of the night or even
Bishop coming here at some point to d8
just defending the unprotected Knight
Queen to c7
really just welcoming exchanges if Queen
takes Queen here rook takes Queen and
the pressure is still pretty persistent
this rook is very nicely placed on the
seventh rank and these these two bishops
are functioning very well focusing in
the Queen side direction but black
avoids the Queen exchange and plays
Queen to eight
and now we have Bishop to g4 once again
notice that this Knight is attacked once
defended once we could consider it
unprotected so that prompts the move
Bishop g4 attacking an unprotected piece
Knight to c5 and white could go ahead
and win upon here the only question now
is how to go about doing it there's a
couple different ways probably the most
direct way and I'm sure this is still a
good way to go about it but white ends
up choosing a different route one way to
do it is just Bishop takes Knight pawn
takes Bishop and then Queen takes pawn
white is up upon and better in this
position if not winning however notice
that this pawn is the only defender of
this night this night is attacked three
times and you can essentially try and
deflect this pawn the defender of the c5
pawn so that's what prompts pawn the e5
pawn takes pawn now we win the knight so
unfortunately this pawn can't move and
the bishops being attacked so we have
Bishop g7 and now the unprotected pieces
the Pawnee 7 so that falls on the h5 a
move directed at I'm thinking not only
to allow the King an additional square
to run to but to turn this Bishop into a
one-dimensional piece from g4 it's
functioning along two diagonals I think
black is trying to well I think black is
threatening it to make it maybe go to h3
where it's just a one-dimensional piece
just functioning along one diagonal but
a little calculation was done here by
white and the game ends in just a
handful more moves
we have pawn to e6 and if pawn takes
pawn we'll just have Bishop takes pawn
the seventh rank is now a bit more
vulnerable that's essentially what this
move is doing this pawn to e6 move by
making this f7 pawn flinch or just move
forward or capture this these g7 h7
squares are more vulnerable especially
if a rook is allowed to get to c7 as was
played in the game after pawn to e6
actually goes ahead and accepts the
offer pawn takes Bishop and that runs
into pawn takes pawn check if the King
goes into the corner to matin to Queen
to h4 Bishop block it's the only move
Queen takes Bishop mate but black ends
up playing King to h7 and that only
delays the inevitable for a few moves
Queen h4 check bishop block is the only
move the bishop is now in a pin the way
you treat that is to usually attack the
pin piece so pawn to f5 will do that
allows the bishop to attack it on g4
this is already reasonable position
Bishop takes pawn King g7 Queen takes
bishop and black resigns and for good
reason if King takes pawn well that
would be the only move that will run
into Queen f6 check if King here that's
me and if came here that's just going to
run into Queen takes rook and white is
essentially up a rook and actually a
couple puns which is equivalent to a win
so that's all for this video hope you
got it got something out of it take care
bye